far cry 5 ended on a cliffhanger about a
year ago and now far cry new dawn is out
is it too soon I think we got different
levels of spicy going on in this group
for when is it too soon to do sequel and
what makes it worth while to do a sequel
yeah I think it's too soon for me by the
time I finished far cry 5 I was pretty
done with it just like mechanically like
that game is very has a very repetitive
structure and well I do think this game
has made improvements that I do think
make it a better game than Far Cry 5 it
still is enough of the same game that
even a year later I like no I think it's
too soon for me like I'm I found myself
kind of bored by it just by the nature
of I'm right now not ready for more Far
Cry
[Music]
mechanically it has to like evolve
itself like this is pitching itself as
like a direct sequel to five and from
like a story perspective it does a
couple interesting things but
mechanically it's I think it's just too
similar yeah I was gonna say like as
soon as I started the game up and it
dropped me in my first feeling as soon
as I had my hand on the control was oh
I'm doing far cry 5 again it feels very
very similar and I actually couldn't
bring myself to finish for cry 5 I got
very far in it but I end up doing like
all the side stuff and I immediately
felt like the feeling of being burned
out before I even started playing one of
the things if you didn't make it to the
end of Far Cry 5 it ended with the
nuclear apocalypse yeah and if you're
somebody who got attached to those
characters then I think what happens in
Far Cry New Dawn would matter a lot to
you for example the main character
somebody you've delivered at the end of
the last game but like your level of
burnout at the end of Far Cry 5 feels
like a big predictor of how yeah you've
done you're gonna be it's sort of this
weird like country 20 where I would say
like I think you would actually have a
really good time if you didn't play five
because maybe you wouldn't have been so
burnt out on far cry and like this game
does make a lot of improvement so I
think make it a better game overall in
some ways but you don't have that
attachment to the characters and the
investment in that world so you kind of
have to like still be like itching to
play more Far Cry and want these
characters I feel like to really
appreciate this game I still think even
with that feeling of burnout I had it
was kind of interesting to see those
characters return like I got excited
when I saw the daughter that I helped
deliver the parents to the hospital
where they had that kid and now there's
someone who's running around with me
trying to do all these missions that's
really cool I like that you'd mention
something about bringing her to save her
father on a mission so she's an optional
character and one of the things I love
about this game is I really do love the
writing well so could you do me
do me a solid beat here and help out an
overworked mommy I mean I read a bunch
of traps with all these high pressure
pipes but they still need to be armed
little blades got me run up my feed I
just need five minutes to myself maybe
have a [ __ ] shaped my pits I love how
these you come back on these characters
who you know and care about and you see
them in a different way for example
Eaton's gate aren't necessarily the bad
guys anymore
the apocalypse has happened and there's
a new you know highway men are in town
there's a new bad guy but you said that
you brought her along on a rescue
mission for her father and they went as
far as writing different dialogue yeah
it actually changes the way the dialogue
plays out when you go and rescue her her
father I think you said you also ran
into it's cuz you had her with you I did
and I wasn't expecting them to do it ya
can slide normally the side character
grab doesn't really matter and I think I
kept her in my party because I liked her
as a character and she felt like she was
important in the story so surprised that
they actually acknowledged that she was
in my party and like had different
dialog for them in a way that in the
rest of the game like when you go to a
cutscene your party member literally
just like disappears yes yeah so they
actually like bothered to write that in
which I thought was like a nice nice
touch
yeah it's especially I just like they
hadn't seen each other in like these 17
years or something that the whole the
distance between the two games so to
actually see them kind of get that
excited and like oh you you go on ahead
we'll all meet you there and we'll
surprise mom together like that kinda
made me feel really happy that led right
up into the cutscene where they all kind
of came together it was really cool
hey baby
hey you know if you're busy I can always
come back nope
[Music]
that is the part of the story that I do
like because I think the overall stories
kind of whatever it's like oh there's
these like twins who were run this like
gang of highwayman and they're the bad
guys and I was like yeah it feels very
typical farcry like I don't find them
particularly interesting and what
they're trying to do
it's very cartoony in a way that does
actually kind of work like the problem I
had with five story is that it's trying
there's moments where it tries to take
itself like very seriously and it didn't
work with how goofy that game is or how
goofy the side missions can be this game
does ultimately feel totally more
cohesive because it's the apocalypse I
feel like they're more free to be very
silly to be silly weird with it and not
take itself so seriously in a way that I
do like more
[Music]
how do you guys feel about that so
because I don't think they go far enough
with it I'm kind of disappointed it
liked it it's an interesting take on it
because you would expect when you hear
apocalypse you'd have like a like a
fallout 3 scenario where everything's
all blown up it's all dusty but they did
the whole like hard reset on all of it
and everything's overgrown and it's
green there's colour everywhere ignoring
the fact that that's not actually how
that works the crafting mechanics in the
game
I was sure like the actual mechanically
you like the way they're working like
everything's beat up and you have to
build things over time and it solves a
big problem that's one things I like
about this game it solves a big problem
that fire Christ had in the past where
you know you clear all the outpost and
then the game's boring or you've pointed
this out you just you get your favorite
loadout and you're overpowered and you
just go through the rest of the game
right exactly so like in in previous
games there's like that weird difficulty
curve or once you get like the weapon
you want you're like oh I'm good and you
can kind of keep the rest of the game
with that weapon and the difficulty
curve just sort of drops because they
make you actually like have tiers of
enemies and tiers of weapons that you
need to unlock it keeps that difficulty
like more consistent throughout the game
and and I think that's a smart change
it's interesting to see how people react
to it of like if you're a hardcore 4ri
person and you expect Far Cry to behave
the way it behaved earlier and not more
like an RPG you might be turned off by
this I think it's gonna depend on you as
a person so I really like how it forced
me to be more aware of my crafting
materials because I'm constantly
thinking about having to deal with the
next group of enemies that are gonna
come up and having the weapons and stuff
ready for for doing it was really
apparent when I was farming out that one
outpost for the one setting gear I
wanted because it drops the the yellow
and purple level enemies on you after
you reset it enough times and I did not
have the right equipment for it right
off that's weird I mean the idea that
you're like I'm farming this area yeah
right here
I got to dress up like Rex Colt it's
very important it's also a smaller map
though so that it's a creative solution
to making a smaller map have more
longevity to it sure and that's fair and
I do think the the pacing is is stronger
than Far Cry 5 like there there it
doesn't do that same
Pettit of like you have the three areas
and each area you're gonna be doing the
exact same thing three times and then
it's like all you're gonna go over there
and then you're gonna get kidnapped and
then there's a story mission like that
was a big problem I had with five is
it's like it's just the same thing feels
very same very same me and this I think
avoids that although I don't know the
mission structure has been kind of hit
or miss for me
we're like some of its kind of cool it's
other times like there's as per we
rescued this guy early on and then you
have to do this like chase sequence and
it was weirdly dull where you're linked
on the back of like a motorcycle and
he's like shoot that guy and I just like
they're all chasing us and then like one
guy shows up I like shoot him the other
guy shows up I shoot them then I go like
10 more seconds then another guy shows I
don't I just immediately shoot him and
like this is not the thrilling action
sequence I think they're pitching it as
and I don't know if that's because it's
just like this game is a smaller budget
obviously than five it's not a big
massive production that's a good point
this game is the strongest when it's not
doing the big things when it's
connecting to the small characters yeah
for example when you get into Nick's
busted plane you like it in the last
game you flew the plane early on or in
this version it's like a busted-up
apocalypse plane and you have that
connection with him that's where this
game's strong
hold onto your lunch
[Music]
but it's weird like also not the big
story missions the little things like
the bunkers a lot of the traps and the
bunkers think there was one crazy
clockwork puzzle and there was one
singing bass fish trap and when you
actually take the time to read the notes
they wrote in that like these people
were sitting in these bunkers for 17
years and they made these traps because
they got bored like there's something to
do to keep them occupied they were going
mean Oetzi yeah that was something we're
retro actively this game is like made
that part better we're in five the whole
thing was like this town is full of like
Preppers and you're all interested in
like prepping for the inevitable doom
and I was like I thought was kinda
whatever in that game they like retro
actively like made it work I'm like Alec
cuz the apocalypse actually did happen
and like now you're actually like
scavenging all these bunkers but I mean
a lot of the missions are still the same
you're still doing the like caches
you're still doing the bases you're
still like like they're fine they're
well-made but it's still the same
structure that I did in five and in some
cases it's just like the novelty isn't
there like the prepper stuff with some
of my favorite stuff in five like
finding those prepper stashes because
they felt like fun little puzzles and
they're still in this game and I don't
know if it's just because of the novelty
wore off but I don't find them as
interesting in this one as I did in five
and maybe that's just because it felt so
fresh and like cool in that game and now
I'm like up there's more of these yeah
the end of the day I think it's just the
gameplay still enough of the same that
at least for me well I do think in many
ways this game is actually better than
Far Cry 5 it's still too soon for me
personally to like really get into this
game I feel pretty similarly I mean it
at its core it's it's still Far Cry it's
fun to run around and shoot stuff and
see things in the world but yeah I I
kind of feel still a little burnt out
while I'm playing through personally I
guess who do you think this one's for
who would enjoy this one the most
probably people who really like Far Cry
5 and want more of that who are like
still itching for more far cry man I
could really go for more Far Cry 5 and
they did like those characters and well
I think those people will actually have
a great time with this game because I do
think it is in a lot of ways a better
game and it's tough because I would also
say like if you didn't play five five
five but like Far Cry in the past you
might like this game but you might not
have the same connection to the
characters it's still told in a way
where you can follow the plot and maybe
that's enough but if you're someone who
like was pretty done with Far Cry 5 and
and needs a break from four-hour cry I
don't think this does nothing
differently to change your mind about
that I'm just gonna keep running around
with my death pig in my blood dragon
fists hey man oh that's we enjoy then
you know what this game is for you yeah
as long as they're having a good time
that's really all that matters